Vinh Nam chính thức có vắc xin phòng vừa SV, VNPC tên phòng trường 2.2 bệnh tháng chính.
Hệ thống tin trường VNPC đã chính thức đưa vào chính 2.3 phòng viên rút hợp bảo hông hấp vừa SV của Pfizer.
Đánh dấu cuộc mốt lần đầu tiên người dân Việt Nam được tức cận lại vắc xin này.
Đây là tí vui đặc biệt sản cho mẹ mầu, người tự sau mấy tối trời lên và những lối tự có bệnh này.
Viên rút vừa SV là tất nhiên hàng đầu với viên phổ, viên phy quản và viên tự phy quản nặng ở trẻ nhỏ của New Yorker,
tưởng dẫn đến nhập viện, siêu hấp, thậm si có thể từ vòng.
Đáng ngọng lại, các bạn này hình chơi có tốt đưa chỉ đặc hiệu và còn khó khả năng làm nặng thêm các bạn tính New Yorker.
Vũi, thật, đây tháo đường.
Tại Việt Nam, Vũi, SV, Lưu Hành quan Nam, buộc phát mạnh vào mồ mưa,
chim tới năm mi mốt đến Mỹ tả phần chăm số ca nhập viên hôm hấp ở trẻ dưới 12 tháng tùi.
Theo quyền cáo, Vũi, S.V. chỉ cần tiêm một mỗi dưới nhất cho thay phụ trong dây đạn từ tình 20.8,
và trong người lớn từ sau mấy tối trở lên.
Vũi phụ nữ mạng thay, Vũi, sinh giúp chuyện hàng thịt tụ động sàng thay gì,
bảo vệ trẻ trong nghiên tháng đầu đời, thơ đường dễ mắc bệnh nhất.
Dưới lượng sàng cho thay, Vũi, sẵn giúp sàng tới tảm viên mốt về tảm phần chăm viên cơ trẻ
sư sinh viên những chúng hôm hấp nạn cần trong sau viên tế trong chiếm với ngày đầu.
Đồng thời gian duy trì hiệu quả bảo vệ cần bệnh mấy phần chăm cho đề sau tháng tùi.
Ừm viên cao tùi, Vũi, mạng lại hiệu lượng sàng tới tảm viên tảm viên tảm viên cơ mắc bệnh hôm hấp dưới sơ đời,
SV trong năm đầu tiên sau tiên.
Chứ dễ vệ sự kiến này, mắt sĩ bệnh kỹ chính, ra nước í qua viên Vũi cho biết sau nhiều năm trở đời,
vừa dân Việt Nam đã có phóx sinh phòng vừa SV.
Bối mạo lưới hơn hai chăm bố mấy chung tâm hiện đại trên tòan khuốc của người thống bảo quan đặt trường
cút tế, hẹt thống tiên chúng viên Vũi đã nhìn trong đưa vóx sinh về và triển khai tiên chúng kiế tối.
Ngay trong ngày đu tiên ra mắt, viên Vũi đã viện hàng trong thay phụ và người cao tùi đến tăng ký tiêm,
cho thay sự quan tâm đặc biệt của cộng đồng.
Bởi sự tiển vóx sinh giờ SV khu sĩ mạng ý nghĩa lớn với hươi dân.
Mà con đánh dấu một bức tiên quan trọng trong công tám bảo vệ su khuẻ cộng đồng trước một trong những viên vụ thố hấp vui nghiệm nhất hiện nay.